foreign
hey Molly welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help
um so we are California transplants
we're one of those oh yes we know you
Molly we know you all too well that's
great that's great yeah
so we're building a house here in Idaho
we
signed our contract about a year ago we
got locked into our interest rate at
3.875 when it goes from construction to
mortgage however our lock is going to
expire one month before the house is
done oh no
like pain and we're now being quoted a
rate at 7.5 percent
which is again more pain for sure it
definitely knocks out that 25 household
income level for our mortgage
um so we've been like looking into other
options
um this option makes me cringe at it
being a Ramsey girl but um we were
suggested to look into a five-year
interest-only arm just to see what
happens within the next few years and
decide if interest rates go down then
refi to a traditional mortgage or sell
the house then
um tell me this how much yeah how much
was how much do you guys bring home a
month
um roughly 10 000. okay and what what is
your mortgage payment currently on the
construction loan
with a three points apparently we're
just
uh it would have been 2 900 a month so
it would have yes and then what will it
be now
about 43. oh
yeah
and
um more bonus we are expecting our first
baby in three weeks so a wonderful
pregnancy brain on top of it well
congratulations
thank you uh what do you and your
husband do for a living
um I work for a company that sells Micro
shares and race horses okay it's very
exciting
um and my husband works um in fly
fishing okay that's awesome
um because I'm just trying to see it all
of this movement of the 10 Grands
uh a month that you guys bring home if
there's going to be any
um like if you see any upwardness in
that dollar amount when it comes to your
careers and seeing okay here in the next
like maybe two three years do you see a
significant change in that income at all
um there's potential for it
um the company that I work for purchased
my old company so I got
quite a good stock option in that
um
so there's money there and then there's
also I have upward Mobility that I can
move and make more money
um
but I don't see it being
so significant so that yeah
I know I know
have you had conversations with the or I
guess what have your conversations with
the builder looked like just in terms of
timeline and kind of what their
reasoning is for the the timeline being
a bit longer what's kind of their
feedback on all this
covid
and you sum it all up all their excuses
are Supply chains covid it slowed us
down they were supposed to have it done
in six months it's now going to be done
in over a year or so it's just like
do you in one of those things whenever
you have you talked to them about this
this timeline and when when it expires
um about like if if there's any chance
they could get it done a month earlier
what's kind of their thoughts on that or
is it just like a hard no
it's a hard no unfortunately like we to
get it to where it is where it's only a
month longer was them moving it up as
much as they possibly could I'm also
wondering like is there any chance that
they could like offer an incentive
because obviously they don't want to
lose you at this point like you're
already under contract for this house
they want to sell this house you know
other people are feeling the pain of
interest rates changing is there any
sort of incentive of like buying down
the rate or something they could offer
you to kind of help this out like if
they could buy it down from 7.5 to 5
um is it is that a possibility that
you've explored at this point
I have not explored it I'll definitely
ask them about it I have a feeling it's
not going to fly
um the way that their contractor is
written is very much covering their butt
no matter what happens
so but unfortunately like they're
stationed they're not going to be
covered if you if they lose you as a
buyer like that's going to be you know a
loss for them as well so I just wonder
from a negotiation perspective
um if you can kind of just sit down with
them you know it's going to be a little
bit nerve-wracking because you're
emotionally invested I can hear it in
your voice it's scary to think about
losing your house but
um I don't know whether you know it's
better for you to have a conversation or
your husband but go in with a little bit
of Hardball of like hey these delays we
are not responsible for these delays
like we could potentially end up losing
this house and have to walk away that'll
be a loss for both of us so what can we
do now what can you offer us how can you
help us make this situation work out
um I like that a lot
yeah I'm sorry you're in the situation
though that's that's hard especially
with a baby coming being moms that last
month is so vulnerable and you just want
to nest and be comfortable so I'm just
yeah my heart goes out to you
I mean one one very positive thing is we
are
we have an insane amount of equity in
this house like since we've been
building it to now like
um just to give you some numbers we're
in for 6.75 and a house down the street
that's 600 square feet less than ours
two bedrooms less just sold for 1.1 oh
wow
we are looking really good in that area
yeah well I was going to say if you did
have to turn around and sell it uh that
was my question so you're gonna get I
mean you're gonna
almost doubled but it's just amazing uh
and I know you probably don't want to go
through the whole process of uh building
again or something but that does give
you the options to actually let this
home or your future home be a blessing
because yeah Molly I just I I don't want
to get I don't want you to get an arm uh
for a mortgage the adjustable rate
mortgage it's just that is a gamble I
would not recommend that and then yeah
and I don't get it yeah and then you
moving in with a new baby you guys
making 10 Grands and almost half of it
going right back out into this mortgage
payment this house
what was supposed to be a a blessing and
a wonderful thing and a gift and an
exciting dream is going to end up being
a nightmare and it's going to be
stressful you're going to be frustrated
that you don't have more margin in your
budget to do stuff I mean it's it's
gonna it's gonna pull so much where you
don't have the margin that you could if
the numbers look different and so at
that point you know there's or a house
is not worth it like it you know what I
mean like that specific house in a
scenario like that
um so yeah I'm trying to think of other
options for you whether it's what
Christina said or
that feels like a high interest rate too
I mean I know I know rates are going up
but even if it was closer to that five I
don't know if you can go shop that or
look at different options when it comes
to that
um I mean I would do as much research
turn over as many rocks as possible
before you make that decision but if it
gets down to it and that this is still
the final situation uh then like you
said the Silver Lining is you're gonna
have some incredible Equity
um to be able to go and do something
else are you guys currently renting or
do you do you own the home that you're
in right now
we are renting a one-bedroom Airbnb I'm
getting very cozy here with the baby
that's so sweet and two dogs that's
great
um so yeah I I would probably which is a
heartbreak but but look to see you know
what else is on the market and what else
you guys could do
um are you do you guys have any other
Consumer Debt
no we are baby steps three four five
awesome awesome I mean four five six
four five six yeah no you're great yeah
that's awesome well and with that option
of having that amazing Equity if the
option ends up being that it's going to
be best to sell the home and you've kind
of worked yourself through the emotions
of this may be a thing we may have to
end up getting the home then selling it
and taking out this Equity I think that
could give you even more confidence in
the negotiations like if you do go to
the Builder and you're like hey this is
where we're at like if you end up
knowing you're going to keep the house
in salad anyways like just giving you a
little bit more confidence in that
negotiation of saying like hey what can
we work out and even potentially
shopping different lenders talking to
different lenders you locked in with
these people a while back but maybe
there's someone else who can offer a
different rate maybe your lender can
offer us yeah that's what I was thinking
Molly I would go talk I would go talk
and get get three different options on
the table just to give you peace of mind
that you're making the right decision
when it's a one-track thing and if this
is my only options all we have that
never gives you options and I just love
options so go search that out before
anything but I'm sorry Molly but
congratulations on the new baby oh it's
gonna be wonderful newborn phase is hard
but it's great but it's great so thanks
for calling